Hello Freak bitches.
So as soon as you have that,
you don't have any data.
So if you don't have any data,
then you've got to go.
How you banning people for this?
Like Ronda Rousey fucking went off today.
It was beautiful.
I watched that clip.
She went off and drop the mic after it was over.
And one of the things that she said,
I totally agree with about marijuana.
She said this in the past too.
It's an invasion of privacy is what it is.
You're invading someone's privacy.
Just like the fact that if you're,
if you work for a company and the company decides to test you and you,
you work all week,
you do a great job,
you work hard.
And then Fridays since five o'clock baby,
it's over.
You want to smoke a joint,
your home,
you worked all day.
You want to watch the walking dead.
You want to put your feet up and you want to get high.
You can't,
you fucking can't cause they own you.
They own you.
They own your flesh.
They literally own your mind when you're not there because everyone knows that
marijuana is not psychoactive permanently.
It's not like you smoke a joint on Friday and then you show up on Monday
morning.
You're still high as fuck and you're high for the rest of your life.
That's not the case.
So if you,
if you,
if you smoke pot,
you will be tested four or five weeks from now,
you will still test positive.
If you don't smoke any pot,
if you,
you get high right now and then four weeks from now they give you a urinalysis
test.
Depending on what they're looking for.
If they're just trying to trace metabolites,
you can still test positive and four weeks.
That's fucking insane.
It's simply a control thing.
It's a power thing.
These people or government people or government people that like to be able to
tell people what to do.
That's my concern though,
is if it's a power thing,
how deep is it?
How many levels does it go to?
How many judges are friends would not admit should find out.
Yeah,
well they probably already on the case,
but ultimately I hope they're on the case.
Ultimately,
Catholic public outcry,
look,
this is a tyranny.
These are a few people that are deciding,
which is this.
Again,
we're not talking about steroids here,
we're just talking about pot.
It just doesn't make sense.
And we're also talking about a guy who passed to World Anti Doping Agency tests.
Those are the most trick fucking tests in the world of sports.
He passed two of those and failed a quest.
I think it's quest.
Again,
I'm a,
I apologize from wrong,
but the bottom line is the tests were not the test that you need when you're
taking away a guy's fucking livelihood and you're finding him for $165,000 out
of a $500,000 purse,
which by the way,
he has to pay his managers.
He has to pay taxes,
he has to be all these different things.
When you make 500 grand,
you don't make 500 grand because you have a manager,
the manager has 10% you ha you might have an agent and the agent gets a piece.
You might have a lawyer,
you might have a business manager,
you might have,
you have to pay taxes.
You have training,
expensive training partners.
All you mean you have to be very strict.
And Nick is notoriously disciplined with his diet.
I mean he's,
he eats all food.
He's mostly Vegan,
except I think he had some fish.
He doesn't need any land animals.
He,
and he does this based on the effect on his body because he's an extreme
endurance athlete.
He does a lot of triathlons and he does a lot of running.
He swam back and forth from Alcatraz twice.
I mean,
he's a motherfucker,
dude.
He takes care of his body.
And if he's smoking pot,
that should tell you the pot's not bad for your body.
It's real simple.
But he's not cheating.
He's not doing steroids.
He's not doing anything that gives them an unfair advantage.
He's working hard,
he's tough as shit and he fucking fight smart and these assholes,
they stole his ability to entertain people and he's one of the most popular guys
in the fucking sport.
When he came back and fought Anderson Silva,
the paper view was through the roof.
And why was that?
Well,
partly because when people want to see what Anderson Silva would look like after
he came back from a leg injury,
this horrific leg break,
but also it's because he's fighting Nick Diaz.
You know Nikki has going to talk shit to him like he did.
Like he got in his face.
He was like,
what bitch?
What bitch?
Like nobody had ever done that to Anderson Silva before.
He laid down on the ground like he was making a sleepy face.
Like,
look,
I'm sleep and you're born the fuck out of me.
And jumped back up to his feet.
He humiliated Anderson completely fucked with his head inside that cage.
That's what people paid for.
And what he is experiencing right now is a bunch of assholes taken away.
His ability to compete,
taken away his ability to thrill people at what he does best.
It's guys worked for more than a fucking decade as a professional mixed martial
arts fighter.
More than who knows how many years before that training and learning how to
fight all that's taken away by some assholes.
We're moving back to Spain.
The and you know.
Oh yeah.
Really?
Yeah.
I mean this was always a,
a temporary visit.
This was a slow nomadic trip through North American Portland and then Spain.
Well it was,
I mean,
first it was Vancouver,
Canada and uh,
then we were in Nicaragua for the winter.
Then we went back to Vancouver and then we came to la for the winter is when,
you know,
you and I had Dunkin started doing the shrimp parade and all that.
I was living in Topanga,
but it's always like a slow move.
And then we went to Portland for a year and a half and now we're going to go
back to Barcelona.
What made you decide to go back?
Yeah,
well we were always planning to go back.
I mean we,
we sort of flirted with maybe staying for a while.
Um,
but my wife's a doctor and for her to get a license in the u s would mean like
going back to medical school essentially,
which she's not going to do.
Right.
Um,
and she really likes,
uh,
working.
She hasn't worked in four years while we've been traveling.
So,
you know,
that's an issue.
Like if she's going to continue practicing.
Um,
but also just that we really liked Spain.
You know,
I've lived in Spain most of my life.
Um,
I've lived in Barcelona longer than I've lived anywhere else,
but you know,
and what is it about Barcelona that's more appealing in America?
You know,
when I first got to Spain,
I felt I traveled a lot and I was actually on my way somewhere else,
but I got robbed and,
you know,
I ended up hanging out and the way Spanish people see life,
uh,
is much closer to the way I see life.
And so even though I was raised in America,
I never felt like this country never really made sense to me.
How so?
Well,
like what we're just talking about like work,
materialism,
you know,
it's all about the money.
Spanish people that,
you know,
the expression is we work to live.
We don't live to work.
Right.
Um,
you know,
there no,
like Spanish cars.
There's no cup holder if you want.
Do you want to get a drink?
Pull over in a cafe and get a drink?
There are no to go cups.
You want a coffee?
Go to a cafe.
They really,
yeah,
there it's like someone should tell them about cups and lids on them.
The fuck is wrong with those tapes.
Crazy,
uncivilized,
heathen fucking cave people.
Um,
sack hops.
You know,
even though Spain is,
you know,
officially a Catholic country,
there's so much more chilled out about sex,
about,
uh,
sex outside of marriage.
Like,
Eh,
whatever.
Just don't tell me about it.
That's the sort of normal way to deal with it.
Um,
women,
no,
you look,
I've lived in Spain 23 years or something,
right?
I get accustomed when I see a beautiful woman.
I look at her and she knows I'm looking at her and she appreciates it and she
smiles and I smile and everybody's happy.
Come to America.
Look at a woman like that.
You're a fucking rapist raping me.
If you heard that my question questions.
I mean fuck your micro aggressions.
I don't want to hear if you're not a fucking dwarf.
I don't want to hear about microaggressions.
Gimme a break.
I mean,
this country is just nuts man.
And like it and I feel bad because they're there.
I love people here.
I've got great friends here.
There are a lot of things I love about it.
Like the,
you know,
work wise,
it's the best place to be.
But um,
lifewise fuck,
I love Spain.
You go out to lunch with a friend,
it's probably going to go till five or six o'clock.
Then everybody just hangs out.
Yeah,
no,
like restaurants,
right?
I'm sitting in a restaurant and we're talking the way,
first of all,
the waiter's going to come four times and ask,
you know,
how is everything?
How are you?
Oh,
how's your day going?
Fuck you.
Get away.
I've tried trying to talk to my friend here,
right then.
Then they'll come and say,
are you still working on that?
This isn't work.
This is fucking lunch.
But my work and on that get out of here,
drive me crazy tips,
20% I go to Portland,
I fucking,
you know,
buy a croissant and a cup of coffee.
There's a big tip jar I run.
My credit card had 10% 15% what?
You just handed me a fucking bag and a cup.
I'm supposed to give you 15% extra.
That's because your boss is too fucking cheap to pay you a decent wage.
[inaudible].